I was never exposed to manicures
pedicures that kind of thing but I'm
thinking if you if your wife was in that
business would she get you into that
well no she she had first of all when we
were dating I had a high top paid back
in the day she did a blonde streak for
me right up the side I mean we've been
married 28 years
we got no old days on my 89 yeah you
know what I'd be right and she would be
the bronze streak and the whole thing
and she would make sure I exfoliated
another thing she got me hooked on it's
waxing I wax my leg you don't decide
it's smooth is beautiful and let me tell
you something man there's some time it's
too quick these pants are just too tight
they tell you there's something
religious and amazing about just rubbing
two smooth legs together I'm trying to
tell you that a guy listen I think you
should go so you you you you don't shave
the leg no because that leaves stubble
the wax you get six weeks of clean
smooth legs man and then so what you do
is you wax your legs you remove all the
hair they're nice and smooth and then
you rub your legs up against each other
this when you sleep when you're taking a
nap yeah you go but that's why you're
not interested in your wife anymore
Oh
[Music]
oh that's the good stuff some kind of
cricket
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you